okay so today we're talking about the
news
that leah leah thomas i believe her name
is
has
shattered
the women's swimming record in mcaa
division one
now this would be really cool okay
except you find out that this is a trans
a trans woman so she was a man about a
year before
she took hormone replacement for a year
she was ranked 450th among men
and then joins the women women's league
and she breaks the record
for for swim some some swim thing
i wanted to see what you guys take is on
this
do you think it's fair
do you want to go very soon
um
it's a controversial topic so
um
it's like
a part of me is like
we want everyone to like everyone to be
equal so if she wants to come out as a
woman like she has the right to come as
a woman but
does that mean she has a right
to compete in a woman sport when she's
got more testosterone levels than normal
women do and she's probably
not
like she's not fully a woman yet because
her hormone replaceable replacement has
only been done for a year so i don't
know how long it takes for you to
like fully be
a woman if that makes sense um
and compete as a woman but i'm just like
i'm not
apart of me is like it's not fair like
she's competing in a women's league
when she was like a man just a year ago
yeah but
a part of me is like shouldn't we start
like allowing this kind of things to
happen i don't know
it's tough it's tough because like we
were talking earlier i would be i would
be upset just imagine if we've been
practicing all season
going undefeated and it comes to the
final game and we're playing against
their starting five has
two
two or three
trans women on it it's just like
we're about to get bodied because
they're
like we've talked about they're just
scientifically just stronger than us and
so it's even it's like
harder to compete with them if we're
already
at a deficit
and so it's
it's hard because you want to respect
somebody's decision for
their choice in life
there's also on the other hand is like
just because you
take hormones and your hormone level is
this
does that
it's like does it fully qualify you as a
woman because there's so much more to
being a woman
and it's it's just
it's like heartbreaking that
because in the states you would like to
say four years of uh college you're
training and if you are in the limelight
like oh this year i'm uh i'm gonna go to
the ncaa finals and i know i'm gonna
swim my best and i know that i'm a
shoe-in to be first place
and then you have someone who a year ago
was a man testosterone levels are still
and i don't know where
her levels are right now but they're
still
higher than a regular woman
and they just come in and
they destroy everything
if personally if i was a man and i was
trash at one sport and i'm not saying
this is what trans women do but if i was
trash i once were it's a cheat quote
honestly i'd be like
because no one no one questions like oh
like if you say i identify as a woman on
nowadays no one questions it it's just
like okay that's what we want to respect
you and then essentially i understand
but it's like as a cheat code like oh i
go dominating this and get a fluoride
scholarship to college get this go play
pro this that the third and it's it's
just
it sucks in the sense because it's like
we we we can't do that because this is
that kind of leeway yeah
as women yeah we can't be like
we can't we can identify as a man but we
won't stand a chance in men's leagues
like we can't do the same thing that oh
like if a man becomes a woman and they
start going into women's leagues like
they'll rank through the
through the like rankings but if we do
that
like we we could be good but we're not
gonna be like anywhere near as good as
like
yeah yeah
and i i always wonder like
do men
do men like care as much when women
transition into
uh
being a man when it's like oh they're a
trans man
and i often wonder like
do they even like think about that
because
i don't want to say there's not
as much in being a man but there's a lot
but
there's more into being a woman and i
always wonder that but yeah well we're
not going to take away opportunity from
them yeah where when the men the men
join our like
if we if i transitioned tomorrow did a
hormone replacement for a year like i'm
not gonna do [ __ ] to a guy yeah i'm six
foot like it's not even that tall in
basketball you're right it's not even
that tall in women's basketball
again men's i get my ass beat
um but
they they come into our league and they
take away the opportunities that we work
so hard like like women
i can't even think of like a harder
working group of people like people in
women's sports we get like no money yeah
we
ask money and we work so hard for the
little opportunity and like moments that
we get yeah and then
like these guys just come in and i know
they're like transitioned or whatever
but you still were a dude for 24 years
yeah or 22. like yeah you don't think
that effects has any effect on your body
it has it has a huge effect i
and i don't i don't know like science
behind it but i feel like there should
be a
there should be a
time limit you're making this decision
it's like it's like if someone
transferred from one school to another
they put you through a um probation
period to where you cannot play at the
school that you're at because of you
transitioning
from one school to another and so i feel
like there should be a
probation period like yeah it sucks but
we want to be fair for everybody
i don't think we should let them in at
all
you can't switch bone density wrist
strength
like
like it's not just testosterone it's
like our bone structures like look
hormones like
change it does it change your muscles as
well i may be ignorant asking this
question i don't know i just like look
it
i just like i don't need a science
degree to look at this picture and say
this isn't fair
like i don't have shoulders
i like i i i'm looking at this picture
okay i can't even think of like what
this
this former dude can take to make this
fair he's just never gonna look like
yeah it's
like can you i can't think of anything
no
is it hot
oh isn't that isn't it like
i know i don't know how transitioning
works but like when
do you when are you fully like
identified as a woman is when
is whenever you
you don't have you don't even have to
take
hormones to identify as like physiol
physiologically like when are you more
of a woman than a man when you when you
trans never
[Music]
yeah that it's like it's like okay if i
dress up like an octopus does that make
me an octopus no i said that so a funny
thing
funny thing yesterday i was going to get
mcdonald's and i was saying then in the
drive-thru and i told my friend i was
like identify as a car like what are
they going to say like no you can't like
no you can't come do it it's like but i
if i identify it as that like
yeah
that's where like
like the line is between
like so
like society today it's like
you can kind of just
do it like it's good because we have a
lot of freedom we can do whatever we
want to like if i if today i just feel
like i don't want to be a girl anymore
which
god forbid
but um
if i don't i have the right to do that
which is like completely crazy yeah it's
crazy but
it is like
like i like the fact that society's like
this like we have a lot of freedom and
stuff yeah but
it is hard when like stuff like this
happens especially as an athlete myself
we
we do work hard trust me yes we
sometimes we have to get part-time jobs
whilst we're still yeah
athletes because we don't even get paid
enough like yeah
it's like someone else can just
like steal all of that away from you out
in the blink of an eye yeah
can you i can't even imagine working my
whole damn life because i don't know
because when i was 18 was when like the
trans stuff kind of first started that
was when the caitlyn jenner like yeah
like that was when it went on the
national like forefront it was when
caitlyn jenner
like that was like a cultural moment
right and
it's kind of sad because i see the
repercussions of people like letting
people live in delusion today
because by not by like saying you are
you're an actual woman and having that
conversation and like
i in my opinion i feel like it's like
common sense to just know like you're
never going to actually be a woman you
can dress like a woman look at them but
you can't carry children yeah that's
true and
like i feel like by letting that
delusion go now we see the consequences
later
because people didn't say anything then
and they just kept letting it go and
letting it go and now like
girls like the girls now today have to
like suffer for it yeah i can understand
that completely i just thought about
something so
you know how in the olympics they have
two separate
uh
two separate olympics they have the
regular olympics and the paralympics
probably should be
a league or whatever for people who do
transition to be able to play with other
people that are transitioning
because it would be fair across the
board
everybody will be they may be
transitioning at different times but
everybody will have before been a man so
they're playing against people who are
just like them
instead of
playing against
women that are like physiological yeah
a biological woman yeah
no i i would support a league like that
yeah i would be all gung-ho for it i
don't think anyone would really watch it
but yeah i mean you could have trans
women out there duncan or something
[Music]